was it hard for you to write with other
guys I mean you are one talented dude I
mean every band you're in is always a
success it depends like an Audio Slave
no an Audio Slave I would have lyrical
ideas that would come to me or melodic
ideas and I would show them Parts but it
was kind of one of those things where we
all wrote the songs together I see which
which is which is not a bad thing it's
like I'm in a room and and we're all
just sort of feeding off each other and
each of us is trying to push the song in
some direction that they think is great
too much democracy in a way in a what
what ends up coming out of it wouldn't
happen any other way so it's just a
matter of do you like doing it that way
or not but with black ho son
specifically in sound gard and I just
recorded it in my basement it's like a
bad recording I played drums played all
the instruments but it's basically what
was on the record just a bad version of
it and me playing it all and then give
them a tape and they literally can
listen to it and say thumbs up thumbs
down